[Musique]
après plus de trois mois de fermeture le
retour des premiers visiteurs étaient
attendus
bienvenue et bon retour buzet on est
dans une urgence systémique ce qui est
ce qui est très paradoxal d'ailleurs
c'est que nous sommes victimes de notre
succès notre intelligence notre
intelligence et les mises en demeure
en début de ce siècle de prendre en
charge les conséquences de son succès
les médiathèques sont ouvertes les
bibliothèques sont ouvertes
quelle est la différence entre rentrer
dans un musée avec un protocole
rigoureux et aller à la supérette et
quitta sa méthode ici il a raison a lyon
aussi un peu démago de ça parce qu'il
sait que ça va être tout de suite cassé
par le tribunal administratif
surtout venant d'un maire front national
on sait ce que c'est que le front
national et la culture n'a bien
évidemment ridicule
il vous utilise dans toute la journée on
va parler sur toutes les chaînes d'info
du fait qu'il a ouvert les trucs et puis
le tribunal administratif va refermer
parce qu'il n'a pas le pouvoir de
décider si si sanitairement responsable
ou pas faire marseille il y avait eu des
juges qui lors du premier confinement
avaient autorisé à certaines des choses
à ouvrir en dépit d'ailleurs du décret
et des mesures gouvernementales à moi je
pense qu'il a raison de lancer le débat
oui parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison
aujourd'hui qu'un musée municipal
moyennant une restriction des personnes
qui entrent en son sein ne puisse pas
ouvrir quand on peut aller aujourd'hui
acheter des vêtements ou des choses
dites non essentielles comment on
qualifier ça maintenant c'est
essentiellement aujourd'hui de la part
du maire de perpignan un coup politique
un coup de communication mais qui ne
doit pas cacher derrière la nécessité de
tenter d expérimentation mais de manière
légale et non pas de manière sauvage
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux gens qui
disent que c'est une stratégie de
communication qui a commencé dimanche
quand nous mêmes des affiches dans le
centre-ville pour soutenir mes
ce coup les réponses a fait partie
malheureusement une phrase touché
polémique
moi j'essaie aujourd'hui de donner un
petit coin de ciel bleu avec un citoyen
parce que ils commencent à en avoir
ras-le-bol tout ça voilà et un ras le
bol ça peut mener loin près dans une
situation et et c'est ce que d'ailleurs
la crise écologique nous nous nous
révélera aussi totalement inédite et a
fortiori évidemment nous sommes pris de
court dans une 6e année mais je trouve
globalement que l'état fait preuve de
sang froid
derrière le mot riches il ya une
accusation de privilèges au lieu de
stigmatiser ceux vichy nous réussissent
un peu mieux que les autres
on devrait au contraire s'interroger
pour savoir pourquoi nous avons en
france des salaires aussi loin que ce
que nous avons on est riche à partir de
combien
gérard longuet à partir de beauvent les
plus riches que le voisin on suscite la
jalousie la suspicion voulait pas donner
de chiffres on peut pas donner de
chiffres c'est simplement idiot et
françois bayrou vie quand même un homme
d'expérience aurait mieux fait d'éviter
ce piège ac et je suis avec se rendrait
donc qui va bientôt fêter son 100 17e
anniversaire qui en effet à hugo vide ça
je peux vous le confirmer mais qui s'en
n'est absolument pas rendu compte
un masseur vous êtes pas rendu compte
que vous aviez le coc vide
non voilà et à nomain pagny bonjour
olivier ferrand
aujourd'hui nous traquons de larian
ultra condamnèrent très active nous
avons renforcé considérablement tester
alerté arrêté j'ai une des vaccinations
ont commencé dès dimanche pardon dans le
design et les premiers ça dans la gorge
matinale et il a été proposé de me
vacciner donc je fais partie de la
grande famille des soignants j'avais
toujours dit que lorsque je co je
répondrai aux critères pour être vacciné
je le ferais tout mon trajet car délit
est long et les rebonds mais on a toute
la matinée ma soeur on est à l'antenne
jusqu'à 13 heures on pouvait y aller
ah bon alors ça commence en 1904 9,4 je
suis en nourrice à la grand-combe
évidemment possible qu'on ne soit jamais
confinés sur des souris encore mais
souhaitable sèche ministre de la santé
et des solidarités
donc je suis ministre avec tous les
vieux ces questions sont persuadés qu'on
y va de toute façon maintenant 1905
alors non on va juste marquer une pause